we have never lived in a time where
brand was this underpriced let me
explain what is the biggest difference
between me and a lot of people that look
like me or me and the companies that I
work with and I get them there it is the
fact that I do branding not sales
branding is different than sales I love
when people come up to me like Gary I'm
a marketer I'm like cool what do you do
well I am affiliate marketer and it's
you know conversion based hop of I'm
like your salesman bro you got your
prospective unless you were producing
content that is meaningful to an
audience on this device across seven or
eight platforms podcast LinkedIn YouTube
Facebook Instagram Twitter tumbler like
like unless you're producing content in
written form audio form or video form
across seven to ten apps on this device
unless you were relevant on those ten
apps LinkedIn YouTube Twitter Instagram
if you are not you are fundamentally
irrelevant in society this is a very
important thing to understand because I
know there's people sitting here who
have eleven million dollar business and
are super happy and aren't even on
social media I get that but what you're
not factoring in is what happens next to
me what's most important is not today I
I stand up here and so unbelievably
appreciative of that reception that I
just got that knowing how many of you
came here to hear me speak but I promise
you as I breathe here right now I
recognize that literally everything I
did an hour ago and back is irrelevant
if I'm able to execute going forward
tomorrow if I start making the wrong
decisions and not executing begins the
vulnerability of unwinding everything
I've done and I think we all understand
society we react much heavier to
mistakes than we do to successes
the reason I'm pushing that you're
irrelevant if you're not here is I don't
think everybody here including myself
has factored in how much more attention
is going here let me promise you this no
matter what you think about technology
your kids on iPads all day you always on
the phone nobody talking to each other
how you judge kids cuz they don't shake
people in the hand and look in the eye
and all the other horseshit that
demonizes technology right this second
the way we interact with technology is
the most basic you will ever see in your
life ten years from now every one of
these phones every one of these video
game platforms every one of these
websites are gonna see like a [ __ ]
beeper and MySpace you have to
understand this here's why there is
nobody here pod committed enough to this
including myself
there's nobody in this theatre right now
pot committed to this enough including
myself when I say pop committed to this
what do I mean I mean every person this
room needs to take a substantial step
back and understand am i producing
enough pictures videos written words in
these platforms to achieve what I want
and the answer and I'll save you time is
no for everybody and for somebody who's
putting out 85 pieces of content a day
across audio video and written word a
day my answer is staggeringly no
meanwhile there are people here who take
4 and a half hours to figure out a
perfect Instagram post because they
wanted to look good when somebody lands
on their [ __ ] profile it's true
the quickest gateway the quickest
execution for everybody here to get
whatever the hell they're trying to get
out of here today is to produce content
on ten websites the quickest way for you
to get what you want in your life is to
produce videos pictures and written
words across Facebook Twitter Instagram
LinkedIn YouTube podcast your website
email text messaging platform period
look you know what's crazy I literally
want to say right now Thank You London
I'm out it is like I'm thrilled to go
into the mindset I'm thrilled to tell
you and if you follow me on Instagram
this is where I've taken most of my
content I'm thrilled to tell you that
the reason you're not producing enough
content is unfortunately you value other
people's opinions more than your own
ambition and happiness that literally
pants 47 can leave a content that you're
ugly and it makes you stop posting I can
go into that I can go into a million
other things but I make this very clear
and obvious the reason I am just
beginning to succeed in my ambitions is
because today is the least amount of
content that I will produce because I
will produce more tomorrow and more the
next day you have to understand media
dictates everything right there's a
specific reason that when there is a
coup in a country that the army goes and
takes over the TV network and the
newspaper communication is the game
maybe because of being born in the
Soviet Union and raised in the US I had
this paradox of being fascinated by a
closed and open system of communication
maybe because I'm an extrovert and I
talk a lot I don't know why but
something came natural to me my whole
life which is communication what are the
things that make people do things right
what I'm fascinated by is the
democratization of media what I'm
fascinated by is that everybody here how
many people here have been following me
for more than one year raise your hand
the fact that 90 percent of this
audience knows that all I want you to do
is run Facebook and Instagram ads and
you still aren't makes me want to punch
all of you and you're
can face I mean literally all I've been
asking you to do for the last two years
is run Facebook and Instagram ads and
you [ __ ] faces still aren't and I say
this because I put it on film because
I'm gonna run this exact video against
you in five years on some platform
telling you that you missed the golden
era of Facebook and Instagram because
now it's appropriately priced and you
guys have heard me if you follow me say
this I regret that I wasn't able to
build my dad's business bigger because I
didn't spend enough on Google I didn't
spend enough I had it figured out it was
called Google Adwords
it was working yet I still was doing
newspapers and Direct Mail and radio and
television because I didn't understand
the context of the moment that I was
living in I didn't have enough
experience to know that I bought
something so good so underpriced
so scalable that I didn't squeeze the
[ __ ] out of it enough when Google
AdWords was the best if you follow me
you've heard me say that Amazon was the
number one spender on Google AdWords in
those early days and literally use that
underpriced attention to be what they
are today I want you to spend on
Facebook and Instagram because there is
a possibility that never in our lives
again will you be able to get in front
of people at that cost let me just say
one more time because I really need you
to understand it this right now and this
is why I yell at myself for the fifty or
eighty or a hundred thousand dollars of
my own money that I spend on ads on
these platforms to continue to build
brand the truth is I should spend more
and this is not a joke
if I didn't have such a high expense to
run my lifestyle because I have a family
that's fancy now let me make it more
basic if I was single right now I would
literally go move in back with my
parents just so I had more money to run
on Facebook and Instagram ads I'm gonna
say one more time
we have never lived in a time where
brand was this underpriced let me
explain what is the biggest difference
between me and a lot of people that look
like me or me and the companies that I
work with and I get them there it is the
fact that I do branding not sales
branding is different than sales I love
when people come up to me like Gary I'm
a marketer I'm like cool what do you do
well I am affiliate marketer and it's
you know conversion based hop I'm like
you're a Salesman bro you're not
building a brand
you've 747 URLs that you do landing page
optimization against and you convert and
that's amazing I being an affiliate
marketer is amazing other than the fact
that it should be called an affiliate
salesman brand is why you buy Nike brand
is why everybody who's wearing jewelry
and watches right now are wearing what
they're wearing because they bought on
brand not somebody cookie them on
Instagram and remarketed to them and
then they bought that watch for the most
part and so I brand and why I love brand
is because it's in perpetuity when you
build a brand you can play on that brand
for a very very very long time why
Facebook and Instagram are special and
more special than Google is is in
Google's heyday it was not that I was
building brand for Wine Library I was
building sales because when you go on
Google all of our businesses are the
same because they're blue letters on a
landing page that you click brand is
when your pictures and videos look
different in a feed look I think I'm
coming out of the gate in this talk and
I'm gonna macro it up in a minute but
I'm coming out the gate in this talk
very tactical about the details in all
my rah rah and [ __ ] what people say and
self-esteem and all the mental [ __ ] that
I believe in tremendously because that's
what gives you the engine you know
you're not gonna execute [ __ ] if you're
depressed or insecure so like I believe
in it but I'm putting it on a shelf UK
I'm putting it on a shelf with you
now because an event that is so heavily
marketed against me knowing that you've
heard a lot of this I need one thing I
need two people to leave here who've
been hearing me pound them in the
[ __ ] face about running ads on these
two platforms to finally say [ __ ] it's
enough I'm gonna do it and and watch
this is very very important and please
don't [ __ ] raise your hands how many
people here have run Facebook and
Instagram ads and it has not worked for
their business raise your hands raise it
high me too
because not every execution works not
every execution works it doesn't mean
it's not ROI positive the ROI of a
basketball for me is zero dollars it's a
billion for LeBron just cuz you didn't
execute Facebook or Instagram properly
doesn't mean it doesn't work it means
you suck attention is like real estate
when Malibu beachfront property or
property and buildings in shortage 20
years ago go up for the market and you
buy it at the right price and then the
market changes you win the attention on
this device and the platform's is going
to change very soon you are a very
unique group of people that feel that
the Pied Piper of this opportunity is
worth spending an afternoon with or two
days or an hour or what-have-you
it devastates me that you even pay
attention to me at all and don't execute
on the biggest gift that I'm trying to
give you just because somebody has eight
hundred thousand followers on Instagram
and you pay them a thousand bucks and
somebody else has 40,000 and they want a
thousand bucks I'm surprised how basic
people are and they think the 800
thousand is the better deal I understand
it makes sense the math is pretty clear
but a good affiliate marketer can tell
you the conversions going to really
matter if you're trying to sell
something whether it's a service or a
product I couldn't push you harder to
get into the culture of DMing
influencers that you think may represent
your brand
or just have big audiences and start
asking them what they would want for
them to post about your b2b SAS product
or your new app or your hula-hoop or
your [ __ ] cool t-shirt or whatever it
may be
all I ever think about I'm very basic I
keep [ __ ] super simple on supply and
demand i overlay attention and then
culture what's happening in it and that
becomes me and I will always do that no
question the other territory that I'm
completely blown away by is influencers
super underpriced potentially super
overpriced but not allocating a couple
hundred bucks a couple thousand bucks
tens of thousands of bucks depending the
size your business and putting it into
that tunnel and that funnel and tasting
it for yourself is a huge missed
opportunity huge let me talk about
another execution I don't really excited
about how tactical I'm getting today
pre-roll YouTube how many people here to
consume videos on YouTube raise your
hands
cool pre-roll YouTube there's a way for
you to segment and target people based
on what they searched on Google and then
pre-roll them based on what they're
doing on YouTube meaning there is a
segmentation that allows you to target
every single person that searched open
houses in downtown London if you're a
real estate agent selling in downtown
London and he's searching open houses in
downtown London but then four hours
later he goes to watch Arsenal videos on
YouTube you're pre-roll can show up
first based on the context and data that
that person created in YouTube search it
is one of the unbelievably strong brand
and sales executions in the game and you
should literally go home and Google
because I don't know what Google's the
proper terminology is of this
segmentation how do i segment based on
google search as a pre-roll YouTube app
verbatim that how do I search pre-roll
YouTube ads based on Google's search
query if you're willing to unbelievably
work and understand how the ads work
and unbelievably work and understand how
the pictures videos and written words
work you will hit paydirt mainly on the
back of what I did earlier when said hey
for everybody that's got it wasn't it's
so weirdly easy the answer is yes the
attention is just so grossly underpriced
and it won't be and so I'm passionate as
you can tell and I'll tell you something
how many people here actually have been
2014 how many people here have been
following me for more than seven years
it shouldn't be a lot but I want to see
it raise your hands so for the 20 or 30
of you you know I got quiet in 12 13 14
15 like I was quiet there wasn't content
wine was done I wasn't making business
videos like once or twice a year a
keynote from a talk as I was doing a
little talking I got quiet because there
was nothing to yell about
[Music]